The reason why my search is complicated
>> is because
am [music] registered
in this specific county.
Okay, I'm registered in this specific
>> Apparently Food Shop's landlord came to yell at them
for being a um a Chinese spy. What? 3 months ago. Maybe we could
talk. If you support terrorists, you don't get the expedited
DMV line. But you're talking about just having a driver's license
and to compare that to the expedited screen [__]
Is isn't it late? Don't you have to
Are you drunk?
Are you drunk right now? >> You know what? It's none of
your [__] business what I am. I think you're super
drunk right now. >> Uh-huh. What's this Chinese face they
I'm your tenant. I You're part of the CCP. You're here to infiltrate
me
and take over my property
and take over my life.
How How does that How am I even supposed to do that? Like
How How do I even take over your
There's ways. You're part of the CCP.
You have your ways. You're a [__] Chinese operative.
Uh I must be pretty successful then.
Have a good night. >> Okay, have a good night.
Bye. That's just bizarre. That's 3 months ago apparently. Okay,
that was >> English that is not correct because you were
right. For strict scrutiny it has to be That is just odd. Apparently
that's her landlord coming in about 3 months ago.
What's the Chinese face I see? That's like Shakespearean, isn't
it? That's like a Shakespearean lie. What is this Chinese face
before me? What is this Chinese face before me? I It sounds It
sounds like Shakespearean to me. I don't know why. It's not over
yet. Oh, okay. narrowly tailored on a compelling state interest.
And I believe that it is narrowly tailored just to get somebody
off of global entry with a compelling state interest which is
to secure them
I told you guys that I wasn't
>> I wasn't lying.
otherwise protected speech. For con- no, it's not their speech
is not being talking to your little friends online about me.
You're saying [__] You You realize I'm live right
now,
You know what? Hey, if you all can hear me, you know what? This
guy is like being racist when he could just realize like if anybody
if he just knew the truth, he would have evicted her sooner.
So obviously way worse than a Chinese spy is like a off with
your blue He just doesn't know the actual truth.
the Messiah is here.
Deal with it. Good night. How My question would be how cheap
is your rent that you allow that, right? Is that Ben Thorpe?
It might be.
How cheap is your rent that you allow that that you don't go,
"Oh, actually this is a problem. I got to go." That you're upset
about getting evicted. That's got to be the cheapest rent in
the world.
I I don't know, man. You'll find out. Okay, well apparently apparently
we're done with this video. Let me find this eviction video here
really quickly.
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Okay, so I got some >> Okay,
okay, okay. Hold on. But it's very cheap for reasons. Oh,
I'm trying to think of like why they'd be evicted. I assume
I assume the eviction would be almost
that they're yelling all the time, right? In the middle of the
night. That's got to be they they stream late. Um they're yelling
all the time in the middle of the night.
You'd like to believe it's because they're a totally like
they're like a totally disgusting antisocial loser. You'd like
to believe that. But probably it's more like, "Oh well, they
stream in the middle of the night, so yeah for being like disgusting
antisocial
incapable of functioning in society." You'd like to think that.
But realistically it's probably just like that is in some ways
like an ideal tenant, right? But I do think I do think it would
be probably for yelling.
I will see. We'll see. >> Bad news, okay? Uh I know that
I put in
I know that I put in the exclamation
like that
as if there's some awesome [__] going down. But yeah,
that's not the case. For Corantos is only that dude yells all
night long while streaming.
Uh yeah. Listen, being a streamer is rough, okay? Sometimes you
just got to yell.
Sometimes you just got to yell in the middle of the night, okay?
Thank God though. Thank God I got to say just as a small aside
before we really get further into this. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Before we get further into this thank God that Chud Logic
is getting his own place because if he wasn't, could you imagine
being in this like I think he's in like a a fourplex or something,
right? Anyway, let's continue on with this this Food Shop's video.
Jesus. So so so
So I'm getting apparently
apparently I'm getting
kicked out of my current house, okay?
On a cordial note, just being because um
it's almost up. All right, my time here is almost up. And basically
I'm not really viewed as like a long My time here is almost up.
Did you have a lease or something? What do you mean it's almost
up? >> term housemate. I've been too loud, okay? Now with
that being said >> Oh, there it is. Loud. Too loud. Okay,
too loud. That's like the obvious one. >> Okay, that's
okay. All right, I never viewed this as a long-term arrangement
anyway. So I'm going to have to move out
beginning of next year.
All right. And you know, so far I have kept the location incredibly
private, okay? You just got here. The Uh yeah. I mean, I just
got here, but at the same time um you know, it is what it is,
right? Didn't you just move there? Oh, I'm just too loud, you
know? That's it. Um so I I think there's two reasons, okay? So
the two reasons that's been given to me
is Christ, they knew that you were a streamer, right? Yes, they
did. So number one was that I was too loud, okay? And What is
going on? I mean, we're just watching this uh Food Shop's been
evicted apparently. I was told this video is very funny, okay?
I'm not seeing it as very funny. It's more just like sad that
they've just gotten somewhere and the the people there are just
like, "No, you're actually too much. Get the [__]
away from us, right?"
Like that never feels good to be just thoroughly thoroughly rejected
by the people you're paying to be around, right? Hey, I pay my
rent. I doubt she's ever missing her rent. And she was there
for a month. Well,
reason number two is that they are looking specifically
to have a roommate that they can be friends with on a regular
basis, right? No way.
By the way,
I just want to point out I just want to point out
that if it was number one
they wouldn't say number two. If it was number one, they wouldn't
say number two, would they? Where would you ever go, "Oh, you're
bringing up with somebody for like an obvious reason that they
could understand." And then you include the other part that's
like, "I really hope you improve over here, but I don't want
to make it seem like I'm doing the socially nice thing. I don't
want to make it seem like it's all that." But it is all that.
Right? Oh, you're like really loud and it just doesn't mesh with
the house. Also like we're kind of just looking for somebody
that's a little more friendly, like a little more social,
you know? That's it's just number two. If it was only number
one, why the [__] would number two be said?
That's just that's obvious to anybody in this situation. If you've
had roommates, if you've been social in any way, you're not going
to say the thing that's like a [__] thing to say.
It's going to make them feel bad unless you feel like it's important
they hear that. So someone who is a friend, not just someone
who is just simply living there, but they have acknowledged that
you know, that sounds weird. Um but like that's kind of what
they were looking for in the end. So therefore that's why they
were um
Kenny's looking Kenny would literally want to live in like a
four or five bedroom house with only That's like Kenny's ideal
That's like Kenny's ideal living arrangement is he could just
live with only
They could debate the age of consent like a hundred times a day.
He would love to do that. What's up, Kenny? >> I'm not
doing any crimes. Uh uh yeah, exactly. I'm just describing your
ideal living scenario. Just deny that it's your ideal living
scenario. Okay. Okay. And then you Okay, if I want to live with
piff Denial. Okay, people actually commit crimes. That's why
who do you want to Still no denial. Okay, still no denial. I
just haven't heard a denial. Okay, I deny it. I deny it. I deny
it. This guy is great. This guy is actually crazy slander.
Okay. Hey, you're just deflecting from >> want to live
with like your favorite streamer, huh? >> live with video
and you know what it's like to live with a criminal. >> favorite
streamer, Addie, ever, Kenny. Is that what you're saying?
That's a non sequitur if she's one of my favorite streamers,
but like this is funny. It's funny. [laughter] It's funny. Okay.
I don't want to live with piff at all. This is crazy. >> You sound
You sound really pressed. Your voice Your Your pitch in your
voice is shifting up and down so fast.
>> I don't. Do you want to tell me? You know a lot about
They do it in secret, okay? They do it in the south and they
do it in secret and you don't know about it, okay? So please
don't put this on me. Okay. All right. >> like piff at
all. I like her despite it, not because of it, okay?
that against all evidence to the contrary on the stream. Whatever
she says something borderline supporting and you're like, "Oh,
she won." But anyway, it's fine. Let's not get any further into
it. I don't want to actually pull examples.
Okay, cuz you don't have any.
I might not. I'm sure I can find some. There's definitely some.
Every time you come on stream you say it, so there's almost certainly
be some.
I'll go find the receipts.
Welcome back. Good to have you around. All right, I'm hitting
play.
That's why they were
doing that, okay? I don't have any say in it, okay?
It's okay.
Uh it is what it is.
But uh Sorry, that was my way of I I don't need a I don't need
supporting commentary on this one right now, Kenny. Come back
after. You don't like the reaction? You don't like the reaction?
Come back after, okay? Love you. Okay, what are you Okay, but
Okay, but see See you. But yeah, that's the two reasons I've
been given, okay? It's very noticeable when you only have the
one in. Yeah, mhm.
Oh, sorry. I already read that. That's so annoying. I've been
in that situation before on both ends. It sucks. Uh you mean
the person telling people like, "Oh, you have to go." and versus
the person being evicted? Yeah. So
thankfully, okay? The people who has had me over are very nice,
okay? Like the deal that they gave me was unbeatable, okay? It
was It was crazy good, all right? Saves a lot of money, saves
a lot of time, all right?
with that being said, okay? It still sucks because I don't want
to go through the process of moving. Like I think the worst part
about moving, okay? Is that I have to constantly do I have to
constantly do it over the past over the past like um 2 years,
okay? Like how many times have I moved already? Four times? Five
times? I just can't find a home, you know? I'm just
I can't find a home, right? Um
Yeah. I I mean I mean it is what it is, you know what I mean?
Notice anything weird about her eyes? Uh no, I'm not a racist.
But at the same time it sucks um that I don't really You have
to move. Yeah. It sucks that, you know,
I move on place to place. Get a place of your own? No, I don't
nearly have enough money to buy a house. That's ridiculous. Yeah.
That's not what anybody means when they say get a place of your
own. That is
Who the [__] Hey, why don't you get your own place?
Oh, I can't afford a mortgage. Yeah, nobody's asking that. They're
saying go find a place that's small that you can rent on your
own that you would sign the lease for and you're the only person
responsible. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, that is That is such a harmful enabling
comment right there. Hold on. Sounds to me like they wanted your
validation and they didn't get it and now they're butt hurt.
What part of what she said so far makes that message come through?
That doesn't make any sense. That person is not listening at
all.
They also knew you're a streamer, so it isn't like they didn't
know that you were walking what they were walking
Yeah. Uh Seeing something experiencing something is obviously
way different than
than hearing about it. Oh, yeah, you're a streamer. No, it's
not a problem. They didn't realize they were going to be screaming
[__] in the middle of the night. Obviously, that
could be a problem. Uh that you might not anticipate even if
you say, "Hey, I'm going to be loud sometimes at night." Yeah.
Just drink a martini, shaken not stirred. Sounds to me like they
wanted your validation and they didn't get it and now they are
butt hurt. >> They also knew you were a streamer, so it
isn't like they didn't know what they were walking into. Aha.
Um
No, I I don't think they were looking for my validation. I don't
think there's any indication for that. Um I don't I don't I don't
What That was just entirely made up. I don't know how the I don't
know how the [__] you just make that up. That's very
weird. >> think, you know, they mean any ill will or any
anything like that. But what did happen was um
was that they had mentioned several times about the noise and
>> Oh, no.
That could totally be a thing here. That
that is crazy.
That I didn't I didn't think about that that like Is this a Is
this a female spaces conversation? That could be a thing. I don't
know. I haven't I haven't decided. I kind of feel like
that would have been caught in the like interview phase before
the person had moved in. I feel like that wouldn't have just
happened, so unlikely to me, but can't rule it out. >> And
you know, I haven't been the best at following the rules. I've
closed my doors and such, right? Um with that being said, okay?
They knew exactly
that I was going to be pretty damn loud, okay? Because they know
what my streams are. They know my videos. They are viewers. Yeah.
Thank you so much for attending Sterling, okay?
Why not just rent an apartment?
Yeah, I mean, sure. That's what I did before all this time, right?
But I still moved out anyway because of many various reasons,
right?
The best roommates are the ones that mind their own business.
Lame, they don't agree with Yeah, I don't know what this means.
Oh, I closed my doors. What?
You're saying in a place where you can't close their doors? They're
viewers?
Hold on.
Hold on. They also knew you were looking for my validation. I
don't think there's any indication for that. Um I don't I don't
think, you know, they mean any ill will or any anything like
that. You guys are running You guys are running with the viewer
thing. I don't see where that's coming from that you think they're
viewers other than the validation comment, maybe. >> what
did happen was um
was that they had mentioned several times about the noise and
you know, I haven't been the best at following the rules. I've
closed my doors and such, right? Um with that being said, okay?
They knew exactly
that I was going to be pretty damn loud, okay? Because they know
what my streams are. They know my videos. They are viewers. Yeah.
Okay, but hold on. Hold on. Hold on. That's way different than
being like, "Are they viewers?" because they know her in person
and she's gone, "Oh, I'm a content creator. Here's my videos."
That's way different from "Oh, they're viewers." that like moved
in or moved her in with them. I I think
I believe they said they were friends.
I don't think I don't Listen, I'll keep it in suspension for
now. The impression I had was that they were viewers like when
she says they're viewers there that they were friends
But we'll we'll keep watching and see. Thank you so much for
attending Sterling, okay?
Why not just rent an apartment?
Yeah, I mean, sure. That's what I did before all this time, right?
But I still moved out anyway because of many various reasons,
right?
Like what? What are the various reasons? >> roommates are
the ones that mind their own business. Lame, they don't agree
with this. Um again, the hope isn't like about the It isn't about
the friendship, right? It's about the Yeah. You could offer to
pay for soundproofing. That's what I said, okay? But I'm just
saying that um Yeah, I don't know. There's a video on that. Wait,
there's a video on what?
Are you talking about We watched the other video. We watched
this already. Drunk landlord accuses accuses me of spying for
China gone wrong. This guy did not sound like he would just be
the average Food Shop viewer, by the way. That's not how that
sounded to me. That's the one? Okay, well, we've got we've got
this one. Was there more in here, Queenan, where she goes on
to talk about the
about like how she met these people or how she moved in here?
Maybe that's relevant. I just stopped after the point where that
guy leaves.
About 2 minutes in.
Why she left the place. Okay. Oh, wait, this is like a different
place. I see. She left this place because it was like a landlord
situation. Got it. It is what it is. That landlord, by the way,
very obvious chaser. That That landlord came in was like
was like a conservative, very obvious chaser. Might as well have
been short fat otaku who was her landlord, okay?
I'm telling you that was the vibe I picked up almost instantly
when he walked down there. Very disgusting. We're going to continue
on anyway. Yeah. I mean, it is their house. So, okay. You said
Why? Why would you ever be doing this? >> If you live around
the Bay Area, Why would you just >> and you have a place,
let me know, okay? I might be up. I might be down, all right?
We'll see. All right, we'll see. I'm not willing to disclose
any more locations or information about my location
um outside of the fact, right? Because like me saying Bay Area,
that's not Uh they're Asian, Ryle. I can barely tell the difference
between their eye color and their pupils anyway. I don't know
how you can. Maybe that's a special level of racism bestowed
only on to you. They're Like literally, I can't tell the difference.
Even if those contacts were colored, I can't tell the difference.
Like the darkest eyes mixed with pupils.
Yeah, like but but you literally couldn't tell the difference.
I cannot tell any difference between these two
Even though she clearly moved like removed a colored contact,
I literally can't tell the difference between these two eyes.
There's like nothing going on there. That doesn't That doesn't
tell anyone anything, right? It's a [__] large ass
place. Um
So
Yeah, just let me know, okay? You have two months. Uh I have
uh four four-ish months. Yeah. Four-ish months. Just me because
they said that they want me out um
vaguely somewhere maybe next year. Like early next year, first
half of next year. Wait, that's not getting evicted. Ish. Is
this just fundraising? You know?
It's maybe like maybe you could find someone who works a lot,
maybe. But um another thing is um so
the problem
is that my search is complicated. Now the She said 4 months.
>> why my search is complicated
is because
am registered
in this specific county.
Okay, I'm registered in this specific
>> I see dead people. Um under the benefits of medical
>> I'm sorry, that's all I can think. That's all I can
think. Oh, benefits.
Her This is literally the the POV of her like apartment right
now, okay? She lives in basically that that Florida trailer park,
right? The thing that's difficult, she's getting evicted from
apartments, okay, housing complex, okay?
Oh, wrong video. Wrong video. Back. We're here.
So it's just she's registered for benefits or something. If it
does so happen that I have to move to another
I have to change my address. I have to change um you know, the
location. And the time that it takes to process the benefits
would take a duration of time if I do not move if if I if I don't
move to the same county again, okay?
With that being said, with that being said um
with that being said Uh this is by the way, you see the comments
over here? Destiny won't take you in. There's a guy This guy
called Destiny, but you probably need to put out. All of these
people are just The only reason to watch this person is because
you are either a yourself or a chaser.
And that is what you're thinking about. You are literally a
chaser who imagines Destiny this person on your behalf. Like
just the the most disgusting bottom of the barrel. Just thinking
about the the people who watch this. Ugh.
In addition, all right? There's another issue. Destiny won't
take you in? No. I I I don't know. Probably not. I I don't know.
I don't want to be weird. What the This sounds weird. Um another
thing that I kind of run into all right? is
I have already begun the procedure eventually
to
get bottom surgery. Jesus, why are we talking ugh why? Why are
we making content on this? Guys, I'm getting evicted. Now to
talk about this is a problem because of bottom surgery. at some
point, okay? So the financial stuff, the
the talking to people stuff and trying to get a consultation,
all that stuff. I've already begun that process. So obviously
this is coming at quite an inconvenient time um as you can see,
Because uh it's not good to move locations in the middle of that,
you know, surgery setup process. Well, you're not moving far.
You might move counties, but is there like county level health
insurance for bottom surgery? Is that really a thing? Right.
Certainly not the best. Um
So there's a lot of
bad factors. Let's just put it like
I have to be on the hunt all right? For specifically a place
within the same area, ideally speaking with
You hear all of the the flags and stuff, right? Ideally speaking
as in No, she doesn't actually need it. She doesn't want to switch.
She doesn't want to be anywhere else. Reuben Reuben donated $3.
What happened to her butt that she would need surgery?
Okay, thank you very much for the for three, Reuben Reuben. Appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you.
a roommate
in order to undergo the operation
I need to have someone to take care of me What?
>> while I am out. A family?
Bro, I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not that guy. Nobody Who is that
guy? Who is that
Oh yeah, we we're looking for a casual roommate situation where
I take care of you after your
your surgery and all of the not just actual follow from that
surgery, but the possible mental follow from that
I feel like this is actually we're witnessing why they asked
her to move out. They actually had no problem with the noise.
They were totally aware of the noise. And then she's like, "Guys,
I'm going to get bottom surgery. I need one of you to take care
of me." And they're like, "Yeah.
Here's your 60 days notice. Please leave. Please go. Please get
the [__] out of here. Please go. Just go. Just
out. So the most ideal scenario
is someone lives within the same vicinity as me.
so then I can mark them as my designated take care of adult person,
okay?
We all see what's happening here, right? Do [clears throat] you
all see what's happening? It's very obvious what's happening.
You should be You should be able to see what's going on here,
okay? She's hoping one of these people is parasocial enough and
close enough that they'll volunteer.
That's all she's looking for right now. That's That's 100% so
transparent. It's so obvious what's going on. She's hoping some
of these people one of these people is parasocial enough that
they'll volunteer and say, "Hey, you can move in. Not only that,
maybe you don't have to pay rent. Maybe you could just move in."
She's asking? She's not asking. She's not ask She's literally
laying it out like, "Oh, these are the challenges of me moving
out." If she was asking it would be far less embarrassing.
She's describing the criteria that is make the the failure to
find this criteria is making her life difficult. Somebody who
will take care of her after she finishes her surgery and who
can like give her cheap rent in the Bay Area. That's not That's
not marketing. Did she say DM me? She might have said DM me if
you know somebody. But I'm telling you she's putting it out there
like she's not just blatantly asking one of these people to be
the person.
But now things are complicated. Yeah. That's why No, nobody's
saying, "Oh me. Oh me. Oh me." They're saying, "Call Destiny.
Call Destiny. Call Destiny." Will this contact even go in? Hold
on. Honestly to God, I just got food and this is fairly [__]
disgusting. Ugh.
Okay. Now you can Now you can see how both people are now the
same size,
Now I put the other contact in because before it was not the
same size. Before it was two different sizes. But now they're
both the same size now. Both big. Can we rent? What? What does
that mean? Be honest. Be honest. How many people How many people
are about to type like
Never mind. Never mind. I shouldn't do that. There's a lot of
dead air going on right now. She listen to somebody talk to her
or something? What is this? I Listen, I was like I should hold
back off of that. >> Oh, but yeah.
Oh, she is. What is the What is the sound? What is happening?
Why did she just AFK and like disassociate for 30 seconds? I
have a spot opening up to rent in in January. Fish out if you
have to move to New Jersey. New Jersey? They mean can you buy
a prostitute for a month? Can't you rent someone for like a month?
I'm not sure if you can borrow someone like that.
Jesus. I'm not going to speculate. I don't want to speculate.
I He has to stay in New Jersey. I have to stay hopefully within
the same county.
But uh yeah, that's the trouble I'm going through. Um you know,
I I don't I don't I obviously I feel kind of sad about it, you
know? Um I was really hoping that I could stay here at least
until the surgery is over and the recovery process is over. But
it just sounds like, you know, it just sounds like um it just
sounds like that's just not going to be the case. Um and uh you
know, it just it just puts a damper on my plans, right? Cuz I
I plan things ahead. I plan a lot of things ahead, so.
Dude, this is the guy who donated the $10. I'd offer, but I live
in Nebraska, where Steve comes from.
Dude, I
Uh there was like this Darius There's this I say it's a Darius
stream. Darius went on some DGG stream last night. And the guy
who was running the stream, he's clearly trying to do like my
setup or something. And
every time there was like 3 seconds of dead air, he'd go
"Love you, buddy. Anything else, guys? Anything else?" Every
single time that there was like 5 seconds of dead air, he'd go,
"Are we Are we done here, guys? I think it's like Is there anything
else, guys? Is there anything else?" I was like every single
time I'm like, "Holy [__] are you
Uh link? We might Maybe I'll watch it. I might I'll think about
watching it. We'll see.
Destiny is It's like uh it was like some Darius um It's like
some Darius and Sushi are yelling at each other. Just the exact
same Sushi apparently accused him of being like physically intimidating
or abusive during the relationship. >> Wait, if you bully
her and she says >> But Food Shops joined the stream. Why
stop saying this? He's not He lives all the way in Florida. There's
no Medi-Cal in Florida. Stop saying that. I think Destiny would
pay for your operation, Food Shops. I think he'd pay for your
operation. He'd pay for you to stay with him. He'd pay for you
to get care in the interim, okay? I think you should just ask.
I'm pretty sure he would, okay? He He would pay for it. >> Miami
sucks though unless you're rich,
I am making good money. I'm not going to deny that part. However,
I'm not making good enough money to the point where I can literally
move anywhere I want and still be in
Does that make sense?
I can now afford a better place, a better quality of space to
rent.
but but there are more requirements than just money, I guess.
Right? This if that makes sense.
Just a slightly better place, you know.
Yeah, I know. The comments are absolutely like dire It's It's
just like a totally dire situation.
Disturbing. It's weird.
I don't know, man.
I don't know why. What are you doing, Reebin Reebin? What are
you doing? What are you doing? What are you doing right now?
Why did that JUST HAPPEN?
HOLY
SH- Thank you though.
Thank you for the three, guys. Six subs away from another hour
of the stream. Just throwing it out there right now.
Good luck.
I'd help you out if I wasn't dealing with my mom's and her divorce
stuff. Well, you don't need to do anything. There are a bunch
of people here who are sitting here being like, "If you live
near me, I'd totally do it. I'd totally do this for you." I hope
they're all lying. I think this is like where the most wretched
people in this entire community go, like afterwards, right?
Like it's
I can't I don't know how to explain the
Like there's no There isn't a single fully functioning, fully
formed human in her chat. Like they are all the absolute worst
people.
I don't know how else to explain it. And not like, "Oh, Findarn.
Findarn one." Thank you for the new individual sub. Really appreciate
it, buddy. Uh not like worst as in like they're bad people. They're
like the most damaged. It's like the island of misfit toys. They
are the least functional human beings on Earth. It's okay. I'll
deal with it.
Gaupa credit? My credit is phenomenal.
Because I'm Asian. Actually, what is my credit? That's a good
question. Hold on, let me check. But I'm pretty sure it was in
the
late 700s,
early 800s.
Pretty sure, but um
it's okay. Yo, what's up, Findarn?
Wait, I don't even recognize that name. What the
Are you like one of the earliest subs here? I don't even recognize
the name. You've been around a lot a lot lately. Jesus. What's
up, Findarn? How's it going? You send like one message a Hello.
Does Medi-Cal cover bottom surgery? Now we're asking the real
questions, guys.
Now we're asking the real ones, okay? Does Medi-Cal cover bottom
surgery?
Not investments. Um
What? Are Are they talking to Is there like a different chat
that I'm missing?
Investments, not investments, accounts.
I don't even see what
This guy is still writing like weird fan
Destiny on the side of the bed feeding her chicken nuggets while
they look They're looking up clip of their ops talking about
how dumb they are.
Oh, boy.
There's just a lot of dead air going on. Wow, thank you for the
two gifties. Let's go.
What are we at? We're at what? Four subs? Four subs from another
hour on the stream?
Not investments. Accounts.
Good lord. I need I don't know why I'm watching this. I'm not
Look, I'm okay with paying a bit more. I'm okay with
having a tough move-in process, okay? I'm okay with all these
things. Um but it's just that
Spruce, well that's a gift of a gifted
>> I just hate moving. Like the process Like for as many
times as I moved in the last like two to three years, like I've
I'm an expert at moving at this point, I am an expert at moving.
>> For as many times as I move, I feel as though like I
can never get used to the process. Like I could I could just
like never I just never get used to the process. By the way,
I I also want to point out I forgot They said, "Okay, the two
reasons were the noise from the stream." And then the second
one was, "Oh, we want somebody who's like social and who like
hangs out and who's capable of socializing with They made that
call in like three weeks.
Bro, that is so fast. Like they It wasn't It was barely a month
that she was there, and they're like, "Oh, this is not working
out." This is not working out. That's like a snap decision.
I've had some roommate situations go sour after a year. Like
you don't make it past a year as roommates, it's like, "Oh, this
really wasn't working out."
Dude, a month? A month? That's [__]
Yeah, I understand, Findarn, that this would not take very long
with this specific person. I do get that, okay? But what I'm
telling you is
What I'm telling you is like literally this person's been there
a couple weeks, and they're like, "Yeah, fine. Listen, we're
not going to kick you out right away, but just find something
else.
This is not working out socially. Like we actually we can't We
can't stand to be around you in a general sense."
I moved like eight times in my life, and I hate it now.
Eight? That's rookie numbers, okay? Wait, is it eight times in
your adult life? Because if we're talking about adult life, hold
on, let me see. So
I had to move into my dorm, okay? Move into a separate dorm,
all right, on the second year. Move into a house on the third
year. And then fourth year I stayed in the same house, okay?
So
Uh Ali, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Two subs, guys.
Another hour. I don't have to worry about that. And then I moved
into my first place in California. That's four times. And I moved
in into my fifth place, which is second place while I was in
the industry, all right? That's when I became when I became streaming,
okay?
Um you could believe this, okay? Hold on. Velvet Moss says, "Sounds
like she wanted more than a regular roommate with surgery stuff.
Why didn't she just socialize more?" Oh, hold on. I misread your
comment the first time. Glad I read it a second
I don't know if she would have brought the surgery stuff up with
them. I I don't know. I I think
I don't even know if I've had roommates for like a month where
they're so bad after a month I need them gone. Like I can't imagine
what would have happened, what horrors these people have witnessed
that made them go after four or five weeks, they're just like,
"No, no, no, we're done. We're out. We're out. Nope, can't be
done. Can't be done. You can't be with this person."
Like you're usually on some sort of behavior that keeps the people
around,
But after a month, if they're just like, "No, you got to go.
You got to go. You got to be out of here." >> I think I
moved another time, so that's six times-ish.
And then seven? No Spectre, thank you for the 17 months. Let's
go. W.
Yeah, so So I moved seven times now so far. Yeah, I I think I
moved seven times now so far in my adult life only. Like Like
if you're including my my my below 18 life, oh that Yeah, of
course, right? But I don't have to handle that, right? Because
everybody else handles them, so I don't really care. But seven
times? Seven times at the age of 26?
I will just be your paypig. >> Oh, hold on.
Oh, thank you very much, Sophia. That gets us up to what? 51?
That puts We'll say 11 on the next hour. We got an extra hour
of the stream. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
I'll turn this one down cuz I do want to do a few more hours
tonight, so we'll turn this one down.
Do 30 on this one, okay? Four subs for another hour on the stream
now. What the It's too much. Thank you very much, Sophia. Appreciate
it. Appreciate it a lot.
What the Okay, am I am I supposed to I mean it's It feels very
obvious what that is,
Like it's disgusting. I don't know why we have to participate
in it.
Am I the only person who can't tell obviously what that is? It's
like very gross.
I honestly don't even want to address it directly. It's very
obvious what it is. [__] up.
Listening to? I'll pull it back.
This is 1x.
Oh, hey. My
Want to take a look at my credit? Like this entire thing is just
gross.
Wait. See, this is how you know This is how you know I'm a I'm
Asian, okay? This is This is a Asian credit, okay? This is Asian
credit. Um
Ah. These people honestly I wouldn't believe it if these people
didn't copy Destiny so frenetically. Like everything they could
possibly do to copy Destiny in any way is just is obviously is
paint by numbers analysis. Complications.
This guy is still posting weird fanfic about her and
You were my Destiny, dark romance summary. Foods stood by Destiny
through every lie and trial fighting his ops and the internet's
hate like a warrior in love with the chaos, five of five stars
novel. I honestly just super prefer people like not liking me
in some way. They watch cuz they like the content, but me as
a person they like don't like, and they like they try to like
argue with and stuff. I If I had this, I would not be able to
do this this stream if I had people doing this in my chat, and
I felt like I had to keep them there. People who do that kind
of [__] with me, I'm like, "Yeah, you go. You can
go find somebody else to watch, you freak." Right? I could I
can't imagine. Dude, I'm like Destiny dark romance. What? Them's
rookie numbers. That's higher than mine.
Yeah, you're fine. What's working? Wait. I just got to send this.
What was this? Have a If if you post that on an online community
knowing that millions of people or thousands of people are going
to see it.
[__] Have a If if you post that on an online community
knowing that millions of people or thousands of people are going
to see it. I I I I have to stop. I just have to We're just going
to go back to reviewing this normally. I
What's a high credit score to you
I'm done. Hello? A high credit score is generally I'm legit I'm
legitimately 740 and above. Yeah, I'm legitimately I've been
gaslit at this point. A martini shaken not stirred. Food shops
relocation fund.
Thank you so much for the $10.
Hey, I was over 800 at some point. Also, thank you for the 10
Australian $10. And yeah, several king Masaki and Porix.
850? Really? What the [__] What do you even do with
the 850 credit? Like what the [__] are you supposed
to do with the 800 Like what what do you even do with that? Seriously.
What what do you even do with that credit? What what do you You
You already get everything at 800, okay?
797 80, no one's going to say no, okay?
Hello? What is wrong with her eyes? I think she's wearing like
those gothic
those gothic contacts.
Right? That make your eye like a whole pupil. She's wearing those
right now. But honestly, she took one of them out and I couldn't
tell the difference. So, somebody told me that this video was
funny. This is like 4 minutes of funny information and then it's
been like her just waiting for somebody to say something in the
chat like the entire time. You sit on your life and do
Be white and then charge. 850 credit is like having a gold YouTube
button. But it's a showpiece at that point.
You brag about a 0.001 difference in interest amounts. Oh, right.
Imagine
Um yeah, anyway, let me know, okay? Bay Area. All right, let
me know.
I'm in paying. Okay, anyway, continue along. Bro, could we get
I would love to see like a dude, a Could you imagine like a timestamp
and like a viewership graph for this person? It has to be a massive
drop-off, right? If I I don't even know how I could do this like
just not talk for that long. I feel like I get like uncomfortable
unless there's dinner in the video. I get uncomfortable leaving
silences for long period of time.
So, like I don't know
I don't know how they do this consistently. This has to be like
the worst for your engagement for like anybody paying attention
to the stream, right? This is This is like content in any This
is totally content. Get extremely favorable personal loan terms.
What why I I I don't even want to get loans because I don't want
I don't I don't want to be in debt. Well, I don't get how people
watch Queenman's streams. Queenman can be funny. Queenman is
witty. Queenman got jokes. He got bants. There's an obvious reason
why people watch Queenman's streams, right? Like I can tell why
people watch Queenman's streams. I understand it. Yes, he can
like not talk over periods, but he's funny when he is talking.
I don't know what's going on here. Sometimes I just take out
$10,000 loans just for fun and pay them back the next month.
What the Shut up. Bro, I don't want to hear it. What do you What
do you think about
>> What the [__]
Why would you say that? My credit is good for emergencies. Sure.
Oh, yeah, I mean yeah, cuz just in case you get into like some
crazy emergency, you have to borrow a bunch of money um more
than you can you actually have, right? That's how you boost your
credit. I don't know. Like use all of them, okay? It's kind of
I'm getting soft evicted.
Are you actually getting evicted? Yes.
Sorry, I don't know what's going on.
I just tried to speed up to get through whatever the [__]
that was.
Are you ACTUALLY GETTING EVICTED? OH!
>> OH, HE'S HERE. He's here.
He's here. He's He is here. Are you actually getting evicted?
He arrived. He's arrived, guys. He's arrived. He's arrived.
Yes. I'm getting soft evicted. I'm getting soft evicted.
I just Listen, I assume
that the number one most opportune time for a chaser to arrive
is when a trans person is in need of a new housing situation,
okay? That's just That's like saying that a chaser is going to
show up like outside of a haunted house on Halloween. All right?
I know that it's going to happen. We all know it's going to happen.
It's not like I'm doing I'm not pondering the orb here. It's
just where they would be. He also has no health insurance and
pays cash for name brand vitamins. Bro, why would you do that?
Why would you not like to subscribe to a premium? I don't care.
Oh, like he has the money to do it. It's fine. How? Why? What
do you mean? Two reasons. Okay, I'm too noisy. I'm too noisy.
And
By the way, like I
That's nothing. And Okay, I'm not his Who's that? Who's short
fat otaku? Uh they're a
chaser like a virulent chaser in the commentary-ish community,
Destiny Jason community. Started taping for Destiny super hard
for no reason. Doesn't respond to any request for a conversation
about some of his opinions. Just basically says, "Oh, this is
the way it is." And then refuses to provide any evidence for
the things he says or believes. He used to be somebody that I
thought was like fairly intelligent. I now kind of just think
he's tired of being honest. He wants to make some money. I think
that's probably I think it's probably like why he's doing this.
He's just decided it's not fun like not making money. Being honest
doesn't make you money. He's probably like
He's probably Aerodite pilled, right? Oh, you know, is it Aerodite?
I think it's Aerodite who thinks this, too. A lot of people will
tell you that like being honest about stuff on the internet,
well, there's no money on that in that, right? Oh, who the [__]
was doing this just the other day? We just watched Was Lauren
Lauren Southern pilled, yeah. I'm guessing he's like that, right?
Oh, there's just no way to make money, guys.
There's just I'm not able to as like an actual hangout friend
within that time. So, that's the two reasons.
The choice of being a millionaire, true. I I mean, I guess you
can actually do out of pocket on literally everything because
you're a millionaire. Yeah. No, multi-millionaire, yes. Destiny
really just makes Destiny really just makes his life harder.
No, no, no, no. It's more like he doesn't need to worry about
it either way, right? But he ends up having to pay more for it,
right? Like you paying more for potential health care issues
when you don't have coverage. Yeah, that's You're making your
life harder on purpose because
Who cares?
They're going to discuss They're going to discuss What is that
noise? Who
They're going to discuss Destiny paying for medicine.
But he doesn't need to Okay. A single cast can encounter anywhere
from 300 to 7,000 or more out of pocket. Yeah, there you go.
So, just
>> Why would you even put yourself through that risk? He's
just Okay.
But he doesn't need to worry about money, so I get it. Move into
Terran's content house. Hell no. Lack of insurance is just a
perfect example, especially about the price of vitamins. Yeah,
that's just That's
I [snorts] get where he's coming from because he grew up poor,
right? He grew up poor, so I understand why, right?
I'll hide in your attic, SFO.
But um I understand why because if you grow up poor, you're probably
surrounded by a bunch of people who got their first credit card.
So, they are just being dumbasses and then they use the credit
card constantly without thinking that they have to pay it back
eventually, right? So, they constantly use their credit card
and they're not paying it back and then they regret it later
on thinking that it's like free money, right? And then later
on, Destiny sees that and he's like, "Bro, this is why you never
get a credit card, okay? Cuz you're always tempted to spend it
on stupid [__] okay?" And so therefore, he probably
has like internalized that part and now he doesn't have a credit
card. What the
Like that's probably where he's coming from because I've heard
this story before. I I've heard stories of poor
who get into credit cards like broke people getting credit cards
and then Is there anything else here about the eviction or anything
relevant or are they just talking about I mean, it sounds really
silly, but trust me, people do this. Yeah. Does anyone know if
that's possible? Yeah. I think they're not allowed unlimited
amounts of using your credit card. Dude, imagine imagine you
are getting evicted. You you start a stream to complain about
this. Hold on a second. Ruben Ruben donated $3.
If she's in the attic, will she be renamed Anne Frank?
Bro, come on. Ruben, you got to stop,
You just got to stop. You just got to
It needs to stop, okay? He's got Sorry, I I'm also just trying
to think it through what I was saying. Imagine making a stream.
Guys, I'm getting evicted. Guys, this is a terrible day. I feel
really down about
50% or more of your video is just talking about Destiny's life.
Could you
that like it's literally in your title, "I'm getting evicted."
And instead of it instead, you just start talking about Destiny.
Somebody starts Somebody starts writing fan fiction in your chat
about how Destiny will let you live at his place.
And then it just goes into like how Destiny pays for his medication,
how he looks at debt,
whether or not he'll own a credit card.
Right? Like it's
I'm sorry, it's just awful. It's horrible. I can't imagine anything
worse than this experience. Oh, sorry, sorry. The storage facilities,
right? It's been done, but storage facilities don't like it.
Don't people just like rent out internet cafe spots in Japan
or something? And then they just live in it. They also do that
in China and in any other Asian East Asian country because they
feel hopeless and depressed and you know, they're never going
to get their own place, so they just go to work and then come
back and live in a [__] internet cafe and sleep.
Jesus. It's a sad life for us out there. Stuck in [__]
I don't know if he's He's a man. Kidding.
Any stories of him sleeping in bike lockers to save up money
while That's kind of based. Oh, in Japan,
Can't stream in the cafe, though. Well, I mean, they probably
have an office where where they work retail in Japan. Okay, this
literally I'm sure for somebody this could be really interesting
to go and see like how much of the stream is her making any commentary
of her own versus just bouncing off of chat answering like simple
questions from them.
Like it's it's actually crazy how little
thought process there is here to run this stream. Like there's
just nothing going on here. It's very very
I just Honestly, it's one of those situations where it's like
the the subject that a lot of people think about. Well, maybe
this doesn't apply for food shops. With Destiny, it's like the
people around Destiny are more funny, more interesting to me
because when I watch them, like I don't understand how they're
being like
What is what is moving them in the world? I don't understand.
The other person's like solved, it's boring now. They're just
like a total
like a total degenerate, total
totally amoral psychopath, right? This easy, super easy to understand.
With food chops And now I I don't think there is something going
on there. There's like nothing going on. So now I'm looking at
the audience. What kind of audience
opts into this?
What kind of audience
opts into like doing this this thing where the streamer doesn't
actually do anything. They don't really add unique commentary,
they don't really make an argument, they don't really do anything.
It's It's insane to me.
I mean I like I'll I'll always be finding ends. Like I know that
I'll always be finding the end, right? Like what is it that Abraham
Lincoln said,
Because you know, do you know why I can't be too mad about it?
You know why? It's cuz I have to be my best self, okay? I have
to aura farm, all right? I can't complain too much, okay? I have
to aura farm, okay? I I have to be able to remain stoic, okay?
And calm and collected in tough scenarios, all right? Uh-huh.
I I have to be able to become my best self, okay? It wasn't an
Abraham Lincoln quote, was it?
Oh. Okay.
Um so the quote is like knowing that you'll be okay in the future
at some point makes you okay now.
Right? Like knowing that you'll achieve peace of mind in the
future at some point, right? Eventually, will make you
What part of the future looks bright for this person right now?
Genuine question.
What part What part of the future looks bright? I actually don't
I
I literally don't know. I actually have no idea. It's not Things
aren't getting
I'll be paying praying this destiny connection pays off. Maybe.
at peace now. I don't think that's said by Abraham Lincoln, but
I've heard it somewhere. Um I think it's quoted in the game um
Getting Over It, right?
Which is a rage quit game. It's like one of these games Guys,
I know this I know this Lincoln quote from a video game. I >> very
difficult.
Right? Where is it? Yeah, Bennett Foddy. Now, let me see.
Okay. Uh this was horrifying. I can't believe I sat through this,
actually. Uh utterly depressing to sit through that. I don't
know. I don't know what's getting better there. I don't know
if anything's getting better there ever. It just seems kind of
like a dire